this morning we woke up and michael
saylor started to absolutely fire off
more bitcoin purchases microstrategy has
purchased an additional 1914 bitcoin for
approximately 94.2 million dollars in
cash an average price of 49 229
per bitcoin as of december 29th of this
year they hold 124
391 bitcoin acquired for approximately
3.75 billion dollars at an average price
of 30 000
per bitcoin of course michael saylor and
microstrategy they have two specific
strategies inside their business they
have a p l strategy how do they drive
more cash flow from their business
intelligence software products but they
also have a treasury strategy which they
continue to convert us dollars to
bitcoin over and over and over again
when you own billions of dollars of
bitcoin some people may take their foot
off the gas they may think that i don't
necessarily need to continue to actually
buy more bitcoin but here we go michael
saylor buying 94 million dollars more of
bitcoin about 2 000 more bitcoin or so
he is not going to stop in my opinion i
don't know what he's going to do in the
future i have no inside information but
i don't think that he's going to stop
he's publicly stated that this is his
strategy and so to see somebody who
didn't have a hundred thousand bitcoin
get a hundred thousand and then get to
110 115 then 120 and now closing in on
125 000 bitcoin means that michael
saylor now owns about one out of every
170 bitcoin that will ever be in
circulation now if we go ahead and we
look in the third quarter microstrategy
added almost 9 000 bitcoin to their
holdings an average of 3
000 bitcoin per month absolutely bonkers
to think about how much bitcoin they
have been acquiring and it's not a
secret everyone knows that they're gonna
do it everyone knows what the strategy
is everyone has the opportunity
available to them to also be acquiring
bitcoin as well michael saylor is the
one who's actually going and doing it so
you have to respect the conviction and
the courage to continue to double and
triple and quadruple down on this
strategy we go ahead and we look at the
microstrategy stock price what we can
see is that microstrategy now is trading
at 560 up about 180 percent or so over
the past five years but even crazier
than that is if you actually went and
you looked where they were trading
before they started to do this to today
there has been a material increase in
the price of that stock now of course
bitcoin's down a little bit and so if
you look just a couple of weeks ago it
was even higher closer to a thousand
dollars per share
and so when we start to think about this
business and what they have been able to
do they've completely transformed it
they've launched themselves into
international notoriety they've
drastically increased the holders of
their stock and they've been able to
change the financial trajectory of what
they're doing my guess is that tesla and
square also are benefiting but you're
going to see more and more companies
doing it my also guess is that bitcoin
will become a staple on corporate
balance sheets over the coming years it
won't happen overnight but it will
happen as more people see what it's been
able to do for a business like
microstrategy michael saylor is
obviously a leader in this industry he
continues to not only execute the
strategy to perfection but he also
continues to go out and tell the story
explain why he's doing it and for us to
have somebody that's been a public
company ceo for over 20 years one of the
longest standing public company ceos
somebody who's as intelligent and
articulate as him i tend to think that
bitcoin's got a great person on our side
john when you saw that he bought more
what'd you think i'm not surprised at
all he continues to double down on his
investment and when you look at the
micro strategy stock it's actually up
around 350 percent from the beginning of
june of 2020 when a bunch of stocks were
down but it just speaks to that people
are actually agreeing with this and his
balance sheet has grown exponentially
because of uh his ability to go acquire
bitcoin at a lower price and then watch
it appreciate over time so he's reeking
the benefits of it i think people who do
not own bitcoin but own microstrategy
stock are also reeking the benefits of
it uh because his company has grown
along with his investment
joe incredible i think uh he's pulling
off one of the greatest obviously from a
trading perspective like the the price
has increased dramatically i think was
our cost basis around like 30 000 or
something so he's obviously made a lot
of money or marked it up a lot relative
to where he's purchased his asset but
ultimately it's nothing compared to
where i think he believes it's gonna go
right he's publicly stated that he
believes it'll be over a million dollars
per bitcoin within the next few years or
whatever so i think we're just seeing
the beginning innings of this in his
mind but ultimately like it's the best
marketing campaign ever right every
publicly traded ceo every person that's
involved in financial markets knows who
michael sailor is now they know
microstrategy etc and the ones that are
making fun of him he doesn't care right
he doesn't give a [ __ ] at all he's
watched his stock uh go up for over 400
over the last year year and a half so i
think uh he's obviously displayed a lot
of conviction and ultimately it's it's
going to be interesting to see how it
plays out because
if bitcoin continues this trajectory of
what we've seen over the last decade and
goes to where people believe i think
it'll be remembered as one of the best
uh financial decisions that a public
executive of a public company has ever
made i think that from a capital
allocation standpoint people always talk
about like oh capital allocation uh how
many uh people think that facebook's
acquisition of instagram is one of the
best acquisitions of all time how many
people think that facebook's acquisition
of whatsapp is one of the best of all
time right you can go down the line
there's a bunch of these that people
will always say like oh was this one of
the best acquisitions of all time
i think there's a strong argument that
microstrategy
acquiring a minority stake in the
bitcoin network could go down as one of
the best acquisitions of all time
when you think of it that way it's like
wait a minute that's a different framing
than a lot of people have been thinking
about it right a lot of people are using
other people's money to do it of course
yeah but just either using debt or or
cash off the balance sheet but like the
entire idea of being able to actually
acquire a minority stake is pretty
powerful right it's pretty crazy to
think that he didn't
buy any bitcoin until i believe q3 of
last year august of last year august of
last year yeah he's been in the game for
only five quarters
that's it and he's got one of the
biggest sacks yeah he said check me out
now